hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today we're gonna be looking at the
gladiator rework I guess you want to
call it I'm still kind of confused to
myself if you want to know what I'm
talking about you should click on the I
on the top right to go to last
yesterday's video we talked about a lot
of the stuff that happen in patch 2.14
and one of those things is that warlord
and gladiators rework has now been
introduced into the game I still don't
know why they did it early as opposed to
releasing it on the exact release date
of season 12 this could be because
they're doing more reworks or something
like that I'm still very confused about
that but we're hopefully gonna figure
out and get some answers soon but yeah
we're gonna play a couple games with
gladiator here I've been playing a
little bit just in the background before
I started this and he is feeling
phenomenal so as I look to be if you do
enjoy and let's get started
excellent so yeah after about 10 minutes
we finally managed to find a game I've
been seeing a lot of other youtubers
talk about this situation as well I
don't know if it's just because PC has
always had this but I've never really
noticed it
I've only been noticing it recently ever
since I've made the the slight switch to
PC just for recording sake because it is
a hell of a lot easier I think it was
around the time of this season the
beginning of it wasn't too bad but I
kind of expected that a lot of people
were to come into the game but at the
very end as we're you know breaking down
the very last month of this season I'm
I'm taken like seven minute queue times
and it's very confusing why it's taking
so long
I understand PC of course is always the
is going to have the smallest player
base but it just feels really weird
yeah overall this is the rework it's not
too bad it's basically what we had in
the testing ground except a few minor
changes once again you can always check
my video that I linked and I also did
yesterday if you want to see those it
there was bit if you know what the glaad
rework is it's basically the same thing
a couple changes were different I think
his sprint speed got changed to be
faster and then he also got bamboozles
Nawal splat which is nice but like
that's so situational and I can't do
that from like and a combat stance like
this so it's like it's kind of useless
but when you're coming into a fight I
feel like it's pretty fair so I don't
mind this I'm also really good close to
dying right now and I don't like it what
what what are you kidding me Bo come on
yeah I mean gladiator is still same old
gladiator besides the of course the
changes from the testing ground
but honestly I'm I'm okay with it I
personally I know a couple people were
like why are you bitching about the
rework like it's really good it's like
it is but I mean let's be fair there's a
way more things that they could have
done besides what they gave him I'm I'll
take what I can get of course but I feel
like there's a few other things that
could have been addressed so but once
again I'm completely okay with this I
just need to maybe get used to it and
then a lot of people were mentioning in
my comments from yesterday that there
was some glitch with gladiators toe stab
doing like 20 damage and I've never had
that happen before I don't know why it's
it's not every time it's not every time
it's more like it's really random but
I've never had the toe stab ever do 20
damage so I I can't I can't say for
myself that I've had it done and I'd
also don't know how to like what's the
problem with it but I mean honestly like
it extra 10 damage I'm pretty sure this
thing's still those 10 damage but either
way a buff to the toe stab is always
nice it's a it's definitely not
necessary and it shouldn't be it there
shouldn't be a buff to it but like from
a joking stance I'm cool with
yeah I apologize from my voice if I
sound a little bit congested / and
easily I've been coming down with some
sickness I think I'm coming towards the
end of it I was I was getting some
really hot flashes or some [ __ ] a couple
days ago it felt terrible but I'm
getting better with it now
this dude is really bad I keep throwing
that stunning tab
[Music]
[Music]
there we go okay I haven't been able to
land the bamboozle yet I want to try
that because I know that it of course
wall splats but I want to see if I'm
able to like get a heavy office I don't
think I can I might be able to but I'm
not sure what I'm gonna be able to
confirm off of a wall flight with the
bamboozle very weird moved a ball splats
poor dead he plays walking dirty
I keep trying to do the bamboozle away
from a small distant life from a short
distance but 20 gladiator players that
understand the range of this sprint
attack like that's pretty [ __ ] far my
guy that's pretty far
that's the sprint detection does it has
never had that much range before I at
least to my knowledge it seems like it
got way more much more distance when you
jump I'm okay with it
I'm not not gonna say it's a bad thing
just something I didn't I I may I may
also be incorrect about it feels like it
is I don't know if you've also noticed
I've tried to every time I do a heavy or
a light from neutral that seems awkward
it's it's trying it's me trying to do a
zone but failing completely and I can't
stop it
cos brutal yeah these lights feel
beautiful I don't like having I don't
like like I stated before back when they
put in the testing grounds I don't want
to feel like a light spammer with glad I
feel like that's just not how he should
be playing but if I have to I'm not
gonna be mad I guess cuz it's better
than just it's I'd rather do damage than
not do damage at all like I'm cool with
it
that was really close I'm on a roll
right now bro holy hell pop it off a
little bit I'm about to completely
destroy this poor man's soul
Oh what Oh cause I'm [ __ ] Christ I
dodged into the wall and I missed I
missed the uh I accidentally got hit it
feels bad oh how well do where does this
where's this Raider coming from brother
Oh excellent deflect unaware if that was
intentional or not but that was really
clean yeah overall just from playing I'm
definitely in the I'm really excited
really liking the gladiator rework he's
not gonna jump I wish he would really
like in the gladiator rework I mean I
feel like there's still a couple things
that would really benefit him saw
changes to like his buckler and stuff
like that but honestly I think I'm okay
I think I could if I it you know what
I'll say it that I'm okay with this I
will I will gladly be okay with this I
will deal with it and I'm cool because
it's better than not having anything and
this shaman ruined my punish I'm really
mad let's try we're gonna hit her with
that skewer feint
happens every time yeah honestly I
thought we had this game in the bag I
didn't think we're losing by that much
Oh a game on the harbour yes please
we've got the same people because queue
times on pc are a garbo so I'd rather
stick with the same people twice then
wait another 10 minutes just to get some
gameplay it's pretty atrocious but I
think we could deal with it I am
actually regretting staying in this
Lobby now - forward heavy oh you hate to
see that oh she's back
I eat a counter I need to I need to
remind myself to do a counter of how
many times I've done a toe stab and it's
gotten an enemy killed like me being a
little support gladiator I need to make
a counter of that because I've done that
so many times I feel like in these past
games it's pretty disgusting ha stupid I
do look back at that kill for a second
cuz I don't even realize I kill them
with the sprint attack from that range
like that's right I don't know what
happened with this race something
happened like either I'm just really
dumb or fries needs to gets on it needs
to get on another undocumented changes
because there's no way it's been that
same distance I feel like I've been left
out I've been cheated damn damn damn
stunning tat damn
oh [ __ ] it back your boy
damn I do [ __ ] me up
Jesus Christ was long with me ha faked
out
aw dude [ __ ] off like that's some gnarly
range on that especially the band the
follow-up bamboozle I was dirty this man
really parried me into a toe step I've
never seen that I'm still gonna die
though ready for my favorite move heavy
feet and a bowl odorous
oh brother
the toes are mine in this game
the toes are absolutely mine this game
about to consume two more of that
viscous meat bye bye
yeah but overall not a bad rework I'm
definitely liking it I'm noticing that
I'm getting a lot more kills and I'm
getting a lot more attacks go like going
and not having to work as hard to get
attacks and take down their health it's
actually not as hard anymore it's it's
not the best rework it's not the rework
that I had wanted but of course I can't
get everything in life that's
understandable I'll take what I get and
I actually like this so this is pretty
nice so if anybody says they don't like
this I had talked to me cuz I want to
talk cuz I don't understand it I
actually and thoroughly enjoy this hey
guys it's gonna be the end of the bait
say hopefully you guys did enjoy and
this is also before the Thursday video
if there's even gonna be a dev stream so
I'll let you so I have no idea what's
gonna be releasing maybe there was a
statement on the stream or on the in the
blog post of why they released this
early something like that I don't know
yet but yeah also uh if there is a video
hopefully I'll see you in the same video
in like an hour if not well [ __ ] up so
see some other day yeah I like to be if
you do enjoy guys subscribe if you're
new I cover the informational side of
water that being the balance changes to
hear updates the patch notes and the
leaks if you want to be kept up today
with everything happening in the world
of Warner and never miss out on an
update definitely subscribe the channel
and I guys thank you for watching the
video peace out and enjoy
[Music]
you